[Musica]
grazie cominciò con una confessione che
come mi sono visto il primo del relatore
sulla lista del meglio sulla rete
pensavo introdurre la problematica e
portare l'attenzione al territorio un
territorio profondamente mitico base
diciamo del mio pensiero su come pensavo
questo territorio
allora riporto la tensione al territorio
dopo queste conferenze molto belle e
molto brillanti e molto promettente
anche di un futuro affascinate però il
fruitore di questa zona mitica è ben
rappresentato dalla condizione di sisifo
vi ricordate il fisico sì l'ho detto
restart sisifo esattamente di tutti i
personaggi mitici della grecia antica
quello che incarna resta sempre
ricominciare
non facciamo vedere l'immagine qua
internet deve sempre portare la roccia e
ricostruire in un certo modo
era l'uomo considerato come il più
intelligente del della grecia e
contemporanee
era come promettere dedicato alla
protezione della gente del monita
evidentemente per questo arrabbiava che
lui era sempre contro l'umanità ha
voluto e ha potuto per un momento
incanterà re scatenare la morte in vuol
dire la morte è sparita per un tempo
della cultura però questo ha fatto che è
stato condannato
io penso che è una zona di terremoto la
dimensione mitica che corrisponde e che
lo stato deve fare parte della cultura e
lo è
per caso lo è però non è assimilato con
questo quando sei un paese come l'italia
che è il più sismico dell'europa
devi pensare che siamo in una situazione
molto particolare che circola il monte
vettore che è chiamato voi sapete
esattamente tutti il cratere sismico
questo cratere mette insieme quattro
regione importante e bellissime infatti
dell'italia e ciascuna una proporzione
del pericolo ciascuno è toccata alla sua
estremità del sentimento di pericolo e
per questo che concludo questa sua e
dicendo ci prende una cultura della
sisma per esempio vedendo questa
immagine sono sono due mesi dopo il 24
agosto pelagatti granda scossa seguito
due volte 1 il 26 in una seconda scossa
a meno forte e ancora un'altra il trent
30 ottobre
e questo sta dicendo l'amiu tipicità
straordinario del delle scosse dalla
dimensione sismica non si fa e non si
pensa a fondamentalmente che quando
peschiamo sulla terra ci prendemmo da
grande scossa per sentirla quando si è
fatto quella del 24 di agosto era il
diretto a roma da casa 3 premeva
abbastanza mi è successo due tre volte
di essere insonnia del genere e allora
nessuno si preoccupa troppo quando è
solo questo evidentemente però la cosa
che ho scoperto in sanjose al museo di
san jose in california che facevano
simulazione e facevano vedere in tempo
reale le scosse si vedeva una cosa del
genere
una quantità cenno minore di piccoli
pezzettini
io sono diciamo mi occupo molto delle
nuove tecnologie vuol dire che i big
data e una cosa che ti viene in mente
quando tu pensi a studiare come il
dettaglio infinito ciascuno di questi
piccoli scosse per arrivare a prevedere
la prossima scossa non sostiene che il
punto i centri di ricerca sui terremoto
lo fanno adesso e fino a che punto sono
gia arrivati o fatto ricerca ma non ho
trovato niente sul momento ma tutto ho
detto
il problema non è la il problema il caos
più grande non sono né macerie
il problema è che lì il problema è la
rottura della dell'anima umana che crea
per car per alcuni questa situazione voi
vedete 308 onore non so se sono 49
scatole per i morti feriti di l'aquila
il mio tutor in paragone ormai la filas
e aperta dice ermanno lisi assessore
comunale all'architetto più ciccone
entrambi affidati tu ancora non te ne
stai e rende conto mare aquila si è
aperta la possibilità saranno miliardari
io sto a cerca di prendere 160 casi se
non lo primo non lupi di più questo è
l'ultimo passaggio di vita dopo sabotata
è finito il pivot o rupilli monoli più
di più risponde dicitore esatto continua
faccio sempre finta di parlare poi
evidentemente no beh allora vela farne
una grande frase è quella esatto
continua lisi abbiamo avuto il culo di
del terremoto italiani ciccone e lì si
conferma il culo che in questo frangente
con tutte ste opere che ti stanno tu ci
sai pure in mezzo non ci sta beh
immaginiamo che questo è solo un momento
tragico orrendo nella storia ma non lo è
non lo è
c'è un grande problema nella zona che
non è così solidaria tra di un momento
quando è appena successa una cosa c'è
questa corruzione feroce all'aquila un
disordine di burraco burocratica
assolutamente manuel orazi ha scritto un
articolo importante su questo e ridice
che per tutto un clima di sfiducia
generalizzata e trasversale ha reso la
ricostruzione un nodo gordiano solo
iniziative portate avanti da soggetti
privati sono andate a buon fine
rapidamente buona notizia conseguenze
una mancanza di visione d'insieme di
territorio quello che voglio con i miei
dell'idea portare avanti e rottura del
tessuto sociale
allora perché si avverte una maggiore
necessità di etica nell'ambiente sismico
una zona dove la gente deve sentire
liberamente la sua posizione
niente incertezza insicurezza e
precarietà e caos politico perdita della
fiducia nell'istituzione sentimento
diffuso di disagio pensati e strano come
per la gente io ho vissuto per otto anni
nella zona una zona ferrario pericolosa
dal canada che si chiama apporto copy il
porto della speranza dove era la più
grande musina o fabbrica di raffinamento
di uranio e raffinare l'uranio vuol dire
portare ai rifiuti e poi si è riusciti
sono capaci di fatti male molto male
infatti la quantità di cancro che ha
successo importo era non è normalmente
ma chiaramente più elevata le altre
villaggi con le stesse condizioni
poi c'è la sensore generali solida
fisica però io ho visto un po sotto
lente fiorentino a tweet ios i favori
stati i fattori st doni iniziativa
locale da qualche palla va benissimo
orazi
l'ungheria al suo corso della chiesa dei
sacconi è un bel segno una bella cosa
l'ungheria non è stato quasi gentile per
i migranti lo sappiamo ma almeno un po
di forza portò lentino l'idea ci sono
molti di questi tipi di cose nel mondo
adesso per aiutare le cose però run for
tolentino e non era una cosa da legare
poi c'è questo posto meraviglioso dentro
è veramente bello e da michele de lucchi
e poi e presty niziativa di ted ex
macerata di portare ha colpito si rifà a
macerata che non è stata un altro
un'idea di cavo male no allora il
problema è questo e la soluzione fosse
anche questo ogni anno ma non ho trovato
quello che l'anno scorso si sono il
lavoro di il sole 24 ore che fa il
paragone
secondo criteri assolutamente seguita
mente precisi su la dimensione max goldi
attrezzata
non è il caso nella zona questa somma
non è molto attrezzata e la dimensione
benessere città smart oss ita felice la
cosa interessante è che ben si vede qua
l'aquila nel né felice né attrezzata e
queste si capisce però se deve qua
ascoli piceno e macerata
ok non sono smart però però sono
annunciate felicità vuol dire che vive
nella zona mitica dentro di che ci siamo
non in più non implica normalmente di
perdere il senso della vita che è molto
freddamente
il racconto di albert camus nel mito di
sisifo
chi ha letto il mito di fisico di albert
camus che uno però importante di una
cultura e straniere francese però allora
andate andate vederle veramente una cosa
che mi dà un po di termina il testo di
khamis si chiude su questa fase si si fa
guardando la roccia della montagna
ritrovando un momento di respiro e non
sa più le forze di portarla ritrova
allora che sarà certamente che dovrà
rifarlo ritrova questo momento dove
posso pensare che felice che una cosa è
superba dance alla magnifica nel senso
di dale un messaggio nel messaggio
sociale come allora creare una cultura
della solidarietà e di dem è la prima
cosa è la collaborazione interregionale
una collaborazione che va oltre alla
religione e propria dove sono anche
tutta la divisione delle risorse che
vengono a la seconda regione dopo un
terremoto dovrebbe essere considerato
comunque appunto abitare comune un certo
modo e provera ceo scorso che
politicamente non è una cosa da dire
specialmente nei posti la gente imposto
ma come si tratta di una situazione
molto particolare dell'italia a questa
zona intorno del cratere
perché il partner perché non farne una
regione una nuova regione che prende
queste zone
diciamo minacciate condividere
evidentemente lui la visione d'insieme
intorno alla città intorno della sfida
comune praticare dirigenza cognitiva e
mi sono molto occupato delle degenze al
collettiva per insegnare ai miei
studenti di non considerarsi come
isolato nel sistema ma come lavorano
insieme
a produrre cose importanti e da imparare
per loro ed a produrre nella loro vita
adesso vi insegna alla scuola di design
del politecnico i miei studenti lavorano
in piccoli gruppi che ciascuna la sua
propria diciamo responsabilità e
ritrovare la felicità urbana mi sono
molto occupato di questa problematica è
come credere una zona totalmente serità
come per esempio torre annunziata nella
costa di baia di napoli
chi è stato al più alto livello di
importanti di lusso e titola quasi
adesso è tornato completamente sprecata
come creare lì il sentimento di
appartenenza e di orgoglio di
appartenenza usato di questo metodo e
concludeva un po su che le abbiamo fatto
questo è a fiuggi vede le scuole tutte
le scuole di fiuggi si sono messo
insieme pur per ciascun e degli studenti
creare uno un tassello un tassello del
che rappresenta il suo lavoro e questo
tassello va per creare un'opera comune è
un'opera d'arte comune la differenza e
iter non è una cosa anonima ciascun ed i
tasselli a un rapporto con la rete o con
un telefonino come un più arco di con
tutte le tecnologie che si possono
immaginare
ciascuno delle dei tasselli racconta la
storia della strada dentro di che vive
il ragazzo e per raccontare questa
storia usa di trans media vuol dire usa
del suo telefonino usa di tutele della
videocamera usa di tutte le cose a
disposizione fa interviste prende le
fotografie delle famiglie che hanno
vissuto con chi ha potuto fare un
intervento o un'intervista e creano un
dossier ciascuno su questa strada
la mia proposta per la zona
lasciateli perdere la creazione
interregionale penso che
cetara mai però la mia proposta intanto
è immaginare una collaborazione inter
scolare cominciamo i tuoi ragazzi perché
i dieci sono ancora capace e anche di
simile ma il futuro è a mano di questi
creiamo una collaborazione una rete
inter scolare dentro di che gli studenti
creando o un'opera comune per la zona o
una pera comune per tutelare tutte le
quattro regioni rimesse a diversi posti
tutte queste ci devi pensare ma ciascuno
racconta il disastro la ricostruzione
diciamola il suo punto di vista su e che
è successo una un'opera un monumento con
esso un monumento che adesso non solo
per quelli che reggono visitare la zona
e che possono usare le loro telefonino
per vedere la storia individuale di
ciascuno
cascone delle case diciamo ma anche la
possibilità di condividere questo
mondialmente e così a tirare anche fuori
come sia successo la società è
abbastanza a tirare fuori del del paese
della zona aiuto incoraggiamenti
partecipazione l'idea fondamentale
essendo di creare un sentimento di
appartenenza e di riconoscimento che
questa zona è veramente il molto più
larga che la città che è stata ferita
subito senza diminuire per niente per
niente diminuire il valore della
l'importanza e di ciascuno e dei
disastri
il fatto è che non possiamo pensare che
non succederanno più e lo sappiamo
perfettamente ma invece di fare un po
come guerre infantry a to quality o
fuori tu fuori ma io non sono toccato si
pensavi che tu puoi essere toccato
non lo farei
no il fatto è che l'idea è di toccato o
non toccato ferito non ferito di
condividere il sentimento di
appartenenza a questa grande opera di
sostenere la problematica del terremoto
è un po questo che volevo condividere
con gioia grazie
[Applauso]